welcome back america glenn younkin it's
very interesting you know joe biden ran
as a candidate who said he was going to
unify america
you seem to be unifying the citizens of
virginia the republican base the
republican party a whole lot of
independents have moved towards you and
even democrats
who appear to put their children in
quality education
ahead of this bizarre and very wicked
ideology
and yet terry mcauliffe number one
denies it's taking place when we know
it's taking place i mean it's right in
front of our eyes and number two
as i said he's bringing in a conga line
of individuals
who are quite radical and
support critical race theory
what do you make of him bringing in all
these career politicians well it's it's
the clear playbook that terry mcauliffe
wrote because you know he really is the
godfather of the modern day progressive
democratic party i mean this is what he
does he he needs to take the spotlight
off of his failed gubernatorial career
he doesn't have a plan for virginia and
all virginians know it and so what he's
trying to do is deflect
all attention away from him and on to
anybody else and so he does he's anybody
who has held office or even run for
office and failed as a democrat has been
invited to come in and and uh campaign
with terry mcauliffe and virginians are
just flat rejecting it they see through
it they know it's all a charade and and
here we are in our campaign talking
about the most important issues we're on
a we're on a 10-day bus tour we're just
finishing up as we head into tuesday and
we're seeing thousands of virginians
come together and say hey glenn where
for the things that you stand for low
taxes the best schools the best jobs
safe communities a government that works
for us and stops telling us what to do
all the time and yet we're seeing
independent voters absolutely vote with
their feet we're seeing the minority
community the latino community come
strong with us that we were endorsed by
the hampton roads black caucus democrats
are walking across the aisle in mass
because virginians want a better
virginia and they know that glenn
younkin's going to work with everybody
in order to deliver that based on some
fundamental kitchen table issues of low
taxes jobs schools safe communities and
this is what virginians are voting for
what's most amazing is that these values
are universal they're not party values
they're virginia values and we talk
about the virginia promise that we can
in fact deliver together on the ballot
is virginia it's terry mcauliffe and and
big government control against
virginians independence and liberty and
this is why we see so much momentum the
polls have had
huge huge momentum in him we're just
racing by him but you know polls don't
win elections votes do and so we're
encouraging everybody please get out and
vote get out and vote on tuesday and
let's stand up as virginians and make
this happen you know glenn young they
have hired terry mcauliffe and his
campaign a lawyer mark elias who was
involved in the russia collusion issue
sort of the money guy between hillary
clinton the dnc
and the dossier that was put out in
other words very very creepy very
problematic
his uh colleague and partner was
indicted for his activities involved in
that he set up his own law firm hundreds
of millions of dollars in dark money
goes into
these coffers to help
him
defeat
republicans who've won
races
are you concerned about this even if you
should win
that mcauliffe
because he's he's not exactly an upright
guy that mcauliffe now hiring this guy
mark elias are going to try to do
everything they can to undo the election
well first this is this is just right
out of his playbook i mean he wrote it
as i said earlier and and this is what a
failing politician does when they see
the sun setting on their 43-year
political career
but but he can hire as many lawyers as
he wants the virginia voters are
absolutely making a bold statement
and this is not going to be a close
election
you can just see us pulling away you can
see us making a statement to not just
win the governor's race but the
lieutenant governor's race with winsome
sears and the attorney general's race
with jason miyara's we're going to win
back control of our house of delegates
we're winning local races all over
sheriff races school board races school
boards matter this is going to be a big
statement and a lawyer here and there
that my opponent hires is not going to
make a difference because this is going
to be an overwhelming victory and i just
want to underscore the point
people in virginia
polls are polls if you don't turn out
and vote
the polls
could turn out to be wrong
so it's very very important on election
day that an army of patriots turn out
and vote
uh this race is being watched all over
the country it's being watched in the
white house it's being watched by
so-called moderates in the house of
representatives and in the senate
and i do want to say this to you glenn
young can you came out of nowhere
you have uh
sacrificed your career
you've had to use a lot of your own
money in this campaign
in order to counter the democrat money
you've run a hell of a campaign
and you've brought quality education to
the force something i've cared about my
entire life quality education to the
fore you are the quality education
candidate
and for once finally a republican has
taken that issue and run with it because
the democrats do not believe in school
choice or quality education or anything
of the sort they believe in the teachers
unions because they
they represent them at the precincts any
final words sir well first of all thank
you for those very kind comments you
know when this all started i had uh two
percent name id and i think the poll had
a three percent margin of error so over
the course of the last 10 months we've
had an amazing group of people around us
but this is about virginians and
virginians coming together yes around a
fellow virginian who in fact is as i
have a moment to to think about what we
can get done i am so optimistic of all
the change we can bring but we're also
standing up for america and so virginia
has a chance to lead like we have from
the founding of this great country and
yes virginia's we have to get out and
vote on tuesday please come out and vote
make your voice heard and let's make
change happen not just for the future of
our great commonwealth but for the
future of our country and thank you so
much for having me on your show
everybody can join us everybody at
younkinforgovernor.com and let's go get
this done well for my sake of my
family's sake and all virginian's sake i
wish you all the best sir on tuesday god
bless you and good luck thank you so
much god bless you too hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else